bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors ces suppressions de
vidéos et des comptes de campagnes par
twitter est ce un coup dur pour donner
le trompe
je pense que c'est une une péripétie
dans un combat qui maintenant été mené
entre ses réseaux ses plateformes je
dirais et le président américain depuis
de nombreux mois voire des années
maintenant on se soit qu'on assiste
c'est que ces plateformes s'enhardissent
en quelque sorte dans leurs velléités de
censure du président américain
je pense que c'est une étape c'est un
épisode et qu'il y en aura de nombreuses
autres d'ici à l'élection du détroit de
membres alors phrase chaque propos
insultants affirmations non vérifiées
est-ce que c'est pas vraiment le rôle
d'un chef d'état d'utiliser les réseaux
de cette manière je crois qu'il faut
bien il faut bien comprendre de quoi de
comparavie si on reproche aux
présidentes donc ces plateformes
reproche au président américain d'avoir
expliqué que les enfants les enfants
donc comme catégorie de la population
bénéficier d'une plus grande immunité
par rapport aux que vite que les autres
catégories de la population ce qui est
une vérité scientifique avait re est
certain maintenant sur la forme dans
l'expression de cette vérité on peut
discuter mais depuis quand ces
plateformes sont elles scientifiques
sont elles la science ont-elles la
vocation de censure euh la forme
l'expression à je dirais une vérité que
personne ne conteste en laissant
effectivement proliférer d'autres
expressions de cette même vérité on a là
une démarche qui est de l'ordre de la
kabbale ou de la mascarade politique
mais qui est en tout cas purement
politique dans sa nature
donc pour vous c'est simplement une
censure de la part de facebook et de
twitter
je pense que les dirigeants de twitter
ne font pas ne font pas mystère de leur
sympathie qui sont comme la plupart des
dirigeants de ces entreprises qui vont à
gauche voire très à gauche et donc ils
ont une démarche aujourd'hui qui
consiste à intervenir de manière directe
parce que l'ascension c'est une
intervention directe en plus de la
connotation de condamnation morale je
dirais qu'elle recèle dans la campagne
électorale américaine est le vrai sujet
et de savoir si cette ses velléités de
censure toujours dans la même direction
pourront continuer à s'exercer ou pas je
pense pas la réponse à cette question et
qu'elles continueront à s'exercer aussi
longtemps qu on leur proposera pas une
contreforts c'est à dire aussi longtemps
qu'on les arrêtera pas en réalité ces
plates formes à la fois se prétend
n'être pas éditeurs de presse pour des
raisons de responsabilité légale et
entend se comportent aujourd'hui comme
de purs éditeurs de presse puisqu'elle
le censure que est essentiellement à 90%
des opinions de droite tout en laissant
tout une floraison d'autres opinions
extrémistes à gauche où par exemple on
peut citer le cas du dirigeant iranien
proliférer effectivement sur leur
plateforme en toute impunité
donc encore une fois on a là une
démarche politique et dans l'explication
tient au fait que ces gens espèrent
finalement une victoire de monsieur
byden le 3 novembre et que finalement
les choses rentrent dans l'ordre je
pense que malheureusement peau ça ne se
passera pas comme ça alors on l'a vu un
donald trump est omniprésent sur les
réseaux sociaux en twittant aussi
souvent on l'a vu en moyenne 29 fois par
jour est-ce que donald trump ne se tire
pas une balle de en pied ou au contraire
est-ce que c'est un fin stratège
mais c'est une excellente question je
pense que c'est effectivement un
stratège tout à fait exceptionnelle aux
deux branches de bons pour devenir
président des états unis il faut un
certain entre gens dont on finit par
s'imposer non seulement à
l'establishment démocrate mais également
contre l'establishment républicain
alors vous avez raison vous avez tout à
fait raison de souligner qu'il ya un
certain nombre de 7,8 notamment dans
leur immédiateté ou parfois sur la forme
un peu un peu grasse heures a
certainement qui emplit nuit mais il
n'en reste pas moins que cette ces
réseaux sociaux en général permettent au
président américain d'avoir un contact
direct avec son électorat par dessus la
presse classique par dessus la presse
traditionnelle
et donc je pense que à la fin des fins
le bilan même d'un produit simplement
utilitaire de son intérêt le bilan pour
le président américain de son
utilisation certes fort original pour un
chef d'état de ces réseaux sociaux est
très largement positif et c'est aussi
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est
cette censure qui va de plus en plus
loin devra d'une façon ou d'une autre
trouvé trouvé sa limite
d'ici à l'élection présidentielle avant
l'élection présidentielle je pense qu'il
ya un certain nombre de choses qui se
prépare notamment sur le plan
réglementaire et dont nous aurons à
connaître dans les semaines à venir
alors on sent dans l'âme trope un peu
ambivalent face aux réseaux sociaux un
coup il les adore et les utilise tout le
temps et le lendemain il est des tests
mais il les adore quand ça lui permet
effectivement de parler à son électorat
sous son électorat et rsa non il est il
un feu louis au total de 200 millions de
personnes qui comme considérable et il
est des tests à partir du moment où il
est censuré parce que le fait d'être
sans sur eux à quelque chose du client
et d'humiliant vraiment d'humiliant et a
fortiori quand vous êtes président des
états unis vous êtes censure euh c'est
quelque chose d'humiliant donc qu'elle a
effectivement eu une réaction qu'on peut
comprendre mais je pense que le
président américain est quelqu'un de
beaucoup moins je dirais passionnel
qu'on le croit et de beaucoup plus
stratégique donc je pense qu'il regarde
les choses sur un plan stratégique et
que là il doit se poser il se pose en
fait depuis de nombreux mois la question
de savoir comment on mettra en place un
certain nombre de deux choses sur le
plan notamment légales et réglementaires
pour que ce réseau soit soit fortement
punis et ça je pense que ce ne serait
pas leurs intérêts se sont d'abord et
avant tout les entreprises capitalistes
soit et l'obligation d'atteindre une
forme de neutralité
quand vous avez des groupes extrémistes
de gauche tous les groupes extrémistes
de gauche qui s'exprime en parfaite
impunité
mais quel président américain au motif
qu'il a exprimé une vérité scientifique
indubitable mais sur une forme qui ne
convient pas à ses dirigeants et qui est
censuré ya là une vraie difficulté
objective
indépendamment des opinions et des
sympathiques on peut avoir pour les uns
pour les autres
il ya là une vraie difficulté objective
me semble-t-il drieu godefridi merci
d'avoir répondu à deux questions je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
philosophie auteur de l ouvrage reload
comment l'amérique invente le siec s'est
retrouvé aux éditions texte qui merci